hello nice to be with you in cyberspace
i'm chad littlefield
uh co-author of this book ask powerful
questions
create conversations that matter and in
this video we're gonna answer the
question how do you start a conversation
in a group virtually or in person so how
do you start a conversation
in a group right after the intro plays
i'm actually going to
show you how i started a conversation
in a group of 282 people i was leading a
workshop titled the art of remote
connection
with people who are on our newsletter
list sent down emails saying hey free
workshop on friday
282 people beautiful human beings turned
up and so i'm just going to queue up the
clip of what happened
right before that workshop and then
officially as we got started and right
after that plays which is about a minute
or so we're gonna unpack the learnings
from that and then dive
into this little ask powerful questions
pyramid
and explore um a little amazing
secret that changed the way that i start
all conversations uh with groups in
individuals whether you're meeting
virtually
or in person i'm chad littlefield let's
get into it
[Music]
so real quick before we queue up this
footage from
zoom directly from zoom directly from me
starting a conversation
a little bit of context so 282 people
hopping in we had the waiting room
enabled on zoom
and the first thing that i did in the
tip that i want you to pay attention to
and just see what happens
is and and to be honest i was kind of
i've been experimenting with this more
and more
is in person even in a group of a
thousand people if i'm speaking i always
look to make
a few small connections just have you
know there's no way i can connect with
everybody at scale before
the presentation before a workshop but
what i
can do is have a few quality
interactions and a cool thing that
happens is
at the end those few people that i
connected with
are always the ones who are like more
enthusiastic to raise their hand or feel
a little bit more comfortable to take
the risk
of sharing and contributing in the group
so here we go let's meet
ginger and nicole hello ginger hello
ginger hello nicole i let you both
we're gonna let a whole bunch of people
in in a minute but i let you both
through
because y'all should connect so look at
each other's names maybe pin each other
and make sure to connect on linkedin and
that's all i'm going to say before we
get uh rolling here
117 people are waiting
all right lovely so um i'm not going to
fast forward the workshop went on for
another
90 minutes i'm not going to cut to uh
the end but you'll see that when we do a
q a and ask me
anything in the end ginger and nicole
were two of the heaviest contributors in
the group and i think part of the reason
is that they're connectors but the other
part of the reason is that
and i did this with intention because i
felt like and thought that they were
special
and i had known i had i had an email
exchanges with a couple of them before
but letting them through before we were
in the session with you know 200
hundreds of people there was some really
magical thing that happened that
throughout the entire workshop it felt a
little bit more personalized a little
bit more meaningful
just to them so now what's about to
happen in the video is i'm about to undo
the waiting room
and let everybody flood in and so i want
you to just watch the first few minutes
of that and see what i
did to start a conversation
in groups or to welcome people and
create some
sense of connection in community even
though we're in
a group of a lot of people in fact i
want you to count
how many times i used people's names
names are like an on switch for our
brain right my theory is when we're in a
group
the more we can use names or using names
as much as possible as organically as
possible
increases the sense of connection is a
really great way to start a conversation
in a group to acknowledge individuals in
that group
what you want to avoid starting a
conversation in a group is anonymity
right well a terrible way to start a
conversation in a group
is by saying how are you all
right it's the in psychology there's a
thing called the kitty genovese
effect it's kind of a gruesome
observation or study but the study was
essentially there was a woman who was
walking
uh home i'm not leaving i think she's
walking home and she was outside her
door in a l-shaped
or u-shaped rather apartment complex so
the doors were right at my thumbs here
and she was walking in she was actually
stabbed and
i was i think estimated in
apologies to the psychologists in the
world if i get this number slightly
wrong but i think there were 27
people that saw this happen they were
looking out their windows they heard
kitty genovese's screams saw this happen
but
no one called the police and
what that is often referred to as the
bystander effect
it's the oh someone else will do it so
i'm not going to so you're driving down
the
street and you see a car accident and
it looks like it's happened a while ago
and there's a ton of traffic you're like
oh there's somebody else is gonna
somebody else has already called i'm not
going to bog down the police and that
might be true in that
specific instance but also when the
bystander effect shows up
um it's the psychology of
passivity it's like it's the psychology
of why we stand back and and don't
speak up and do something and one way to
decrease that anonymity and create a
more cohesive
community and a group is to use people's
names so
i think that's enough framing just count
how many times i use names
in this quick little clip i'm gonna let
everybody flood in so um
i see you i love you i'm glad you're
here and i'm gonna let 120 more people
in
all right hey welcome
welcome hi jack hi melissa
oh it's good to see smiling faces
suzanne
it's nice to see suzanne is this like
our third zoom like we did the annual
conference at the beginning like
we're we're going at it i love it isaac
you're cheering did you
were you kickstarter supporter nice hi
stacy bud
good to see you hi jen cassarcy good to
see you
i totally butchered your name there jen
casir
now really important reminder is i'm not
just sharing people's names
with no intention you saw there was a
few times that i
uh had personal contact so i knew you
know i had there were clients on that
call there were people that i'd worked
with in the past
people who i exchanged emails with
people maybe who have even left comments
on youtube videos if they liked the
video
and so i was making personal connections
rather than just saying right like the
trick is not
it's not a trick to begin with but the
idea is not to say
um hi bye bye bye bye and just rattle
off a bunch of names
that you see on zoom gallery view that
doesn't really create connection if
anything it might actually
create that separation so as much as
possible as organically as possible and
depending on your group size that might
only be three or four names
but it still breaks down that effect of
anonymity
and says i see you and that's where i
want to go and unpack the second
um rung and the second layer of this ask
powerful questions pyramid i see you
so if you can uh look at this pyramid
this would be really cool if you had a
magic wand
and your goal was to start a
conversation in a group virtually or in
person it would be really convenient if
you could do it in a way that just said
all at once
i'm willing to know you i see you i hear
you i get you i'm with you right that
would be
a convenient maybe over the top but it
would be convenient to be able to just
snap your fingers and do that not
possible
and so uh what we've developed what will
and i have created
is this how-to pyramid that
unpacks and helps create this impact and
so at this level
i see you names are one part of that but
a bigger part of that
is our own natural genuine curiosity
when we are naturally curious about
other people it's obvious
when we're asking questions out of
obligation or we're not genuinely
curious
it is also obvious and so one other
really great way to start a conversation
in a group virtually is to be curious
about one very specific thing in that
group so you can start
a whole flood of connections if you just
say hey
joe i saw that post on linkedin that you
did what's the story behind that so
asking that question
and hearing joe's response connections
are kind of this exponential thing that
when somebody shares something everybody
in a group
is inclined to see themselves in
whatever's being shared so when joe
answers
it's likely that somebody else will be
oh me too or oh no way what about this
or i didn't know you lived here or
there's gonna be all these connections
that jump in and so the path to start a
conversation
in a group might just be one specific
curiosity one question
so you're inviting contribution from one
person you're kind of
facilitating that as opposed to the
anonymous way of
how are you all doing if you've got a
really engaged group they might answer
that
but it's really easy for the critics and
consumers to sit back and be really
passive in that conversation so if you
really want to invite everybody
in and create this culture of connection
belonging and trust and inclusion
ironically one really great pathway to
start
is curiosity about just one person
when they answer everyone else can see
themselves and comment
how they see themselves in that response
and you can help facilitate that
along this entire video was based off of
like a first
one minute of a two-hour workshop of an
entire series
on the art of remote connection and
several activities exercises that we did
breaking down that so you can check out
the link in the description
and these videos right here are really
great follow-ups if you enjoyed this
content want to dive a little bit deeper
want to be
a better connector in the world i'm chad
littlefield have an awesome day